l' empire disney avance s'enrichit et
devient de plus en plus imposants et si
certains ne le savent pas le géant
disney a racheté la fox
originellement appelé fox broadcasting
company la fox est en gros un réseau de
télévision commerciale géré par
justement la fox entertainment dedans et
compris twenty one century fox dont le
jingle est mondialement connu mais
justement disney a racheté cette
dernière et possède donc la fox
entièrement dont la plupart de ces
propriétés cinématographique
c'était le but de disney d'ailleurs ils
sont censés posséder les locaux et
s'installer de denvers fin d'été 2019
ce sera à ce moment précis que disney
sera le réel leader du cogné au réseau
de télévision maintenant
tournons-nous plus exactement vers le
côté cinématographique du rachat et en
particulier marvel marvel est possédé
par disney depuis maintenant quelques
années et de nombreux films sont sortis
avec les aventures d'iron man captain
america spider man et même carrément les
avengers pour vous donner un exemple
cependant d'autres héros de marvel
existent et sont très loin de faire
partie des films avengers alors qu'ils
en ont les capacités
eh bien ces rôles appartenait justement
la fox et c'est pour cela que l' on les
voyait jamais en compagnie de tony stark
docteur strange store ou autres héros je
pense par exemple à des poules les x men
ou encore les quatre fantastiques mais
maintenant que disney a racheté à fox
ils sont en possession de ces euros et
ils font partie intégrante du même
l'univers que les avengers
les simpson appartiennent aussi à disney
d'ailleurs maintenant néanmoins
aujourd'hui que pourrait-il se passer
tout nous laisse croire que ces héros
vont apparaître dans les prochains films
marvel à partir de 2020 mais est ce que
disney prendrait le risque d'intégrer
ses héros dans l'univers avengers est
donc peut-être alourdir voir nuire la
saga des marvel
n'oubliez pas que disney veut faire de
l'argent et commence réellement être en
possession de tous les géants du cinéma
j'aimerais vraiment en débattre avec
vous dans les commentaires cependant
j'aurais peut-être une autre vision pour
le futur de marvel et des avengers
disney a racheté lucasfilm et donc star
wars il ya quelques temps déjà et ceux
ci donna naissance à la trilogie du 7 8
9 ainsi que d'autres spin off
mais justement sans disney starwars
serait en fait arrêter à l'épisode 6 et
aucune suite n'aurait été apportées ils
sont donc devenus les créateurs du
nouveau star wars alors que justement
disney aussi en possession de marvel et
même s'ils ont été rachetés il y à de
nombreuses années par la firme disney
marvel reste maître de ses films et sont
ceux qui les produisent
alors pourquoi prendre le risque de
s'occuper d'une saga qui fonctionne déjà
énormément sur une grosse intervention
de disney dedans il était obligé pour
lucasfilm qui ne prévoyait plus aucun
film star wars mais si ce n'est pas le
cas mais le but de disney maintenant
atteint celui de posséder tous les héros
de marvel en rachetant la fox possède
donc les pleins pouvoirs sur tout ce qui
concerne les super héros de la firme
marvel est la question que je vous pose
serait que est ce que disney
et à force de vouloir tout posséder et
tout contrôler ne finiront-ils pas par
gâcher toutes les grosses licences
qu'ils ont maintenant acquise
j'espère en tout cas que cette vidéo
vous aura plu merci à tous ceux qui
laisseront un pouce bleus et qui
partageront la vidéo suivez moi sur
twitter c'est très important pour la
chaîne cet argot rock et que le liner
soit avec vous
[Musique]